my name is Alan Johnson off I'm an
associate professor of biological
engineering here at MIT and i also have
appointments in the McGovern Institute
in the department's of brain and
cognitive sciences and nuclear science
and engineering a very talented student
in my lab had the idea that we could try
to make a dopamine sensor by modifying a
protein that we knew should be an MRI
contrast agent so my student Mikhail
Shapiro took this protein and he used a
technique called directed evolution
which is one of the advanced protein
engineering techniques out there and
it's a technique that's been pioneered
in part by a lady we collaborated with
professor Francis Arnold of Caltech so
what Mikhail did was he applied this
directed evolution on a heem protein
protein like hemoglobin that contains
iron looks red and blissfully for us is
an MRI contrast agent he evolved it to
bind dopamine and he found that by
basically mimicking nature's process of
natural selection and and generation of
mutations or generation of diversity we
could actually find variants of the
protein that bound dopamine at
concentrations that could be produced in
in a working brain what does that do for
us the protein generally tends to
brighten MRI signal because it's a
contrast agent but when dopamine sticks
to it it doesn't brighten the signal as
much in fact if there's enough dopamine
it doesn't brighten the signal at all
what that means is that if we take this
protein and we stick it into the brain
and then dopamine is modulated by us
medley so far we could actually see
signal changes due to that modulation so
dopamine is involved in the brain's
experience of reward and it's also
involved in restructuring synaptic
connections that little detailed subset
of their connections between neurons
that underlie neural circuits and what
we'd really love to be able to do is to
map the spatial and the temporal
patterns of dopamine release across the
brain as an animal learn something